à 13 ans maxence a une passion il toupie
mais attention pas n'importe quel toupet
les beyblade loin de la toupie en bois
celle ci est très sophistiqué et maxence
les connais par coeur
celle là elle s'appelle ce prix gagnent
requiem donc elle vient du japon
sa pointe c'est rien que ça pointe l aps
l
trois capacités là c'est une boule
normal donc de type défense quand on
lève et on tourne on a un truc plat pour
l' attaque pour revenir tous et non pas
trop compliqué et ben en fait je me suis
je me dis c'est aussi et en fait ce nom
parce que je dis ça prend pas ça rentre
dans ma tête tout seul et donc là ces
galaxies de tron qui a gagné parce que
celle ci s'est arrêtée en premier au
total il en possède 70 avec des lanceurs
étaient à rennes pour faire du combat
attention 3 2 1 peut faire une passion
que maxence aime partager notamment avec
son petit frère on sait partage ont fait
ressembler parfois avec mon père ou mère
ou ma grand-mère même avec ses camarades
du collège il a même monté un club de
beyblade
alors naturellement elle souhaitait
apporter cet univers dans sa ville son
idée créer un tournoi pour trouver de
l'aide il s'est tourné vers le conseil
municipal des jeunes à mon top départ va
falloir qu'on se fasse une réunion
d'arbitrage on se réunit tous et ensuite
on met change les rôles maxence il est
venu nous a proposé de dornes égaliser
un tournoi de tokyo
il est
on a parlé et ton était motivée alors on
l'a fait
pour l'instant ça se passe ça fait
quelques mois qu'on sent que ça se
termine pour autant qu'on puisse le
faire
dernière réunion avant le grand jour du
tournoi les jeunes ont travaillé durant
un trimestre pour que tout se passe bien
les idées c'est les leurs
les commandes scellé leur donc moi je ne
fais que transmettre leurs idées je
peaufine mais sinon mais on peut dire
qu'ils l'ont fait de a à z ce samedi
maxence aura l'honneur d'arbitrer la
grande finale
prochaine étape pour le champion le
tournoi officiel de parler d'eux où il
espère bien remporter sa place pour la
grande finale de la japan expo